so we have two different substances here
and just for the sake of an argument
let's assume that they are in their
liquid state well you probably already
recognize this substance right here each
molecule has one oxygen atom and two
hydrogen atoms this is a water and we
have drawn all the neat hydrogen bonds
right over there now this substance at
least right now might be a little less
familiar to you might recognize you have
an OHA pist l's you that and then you
have a carbon chain this tells you that
this is an alcohol and what type of
alcohol well you have two carbons here
so this is ethyl alcohol or known as
ethanol so this right over here let me
write that down
this is ethanol which is the primary
constituent in the alcohol that people
drink it's also an additive in two in
two car fuel but what I want to think
about here is if we assume that both of
these are in their liquid state and
we're let's say they're there hanging
out in a cup and we're just at you know
sea level so it's just standard standard
pressure conditions which one which one
is going to be easier to vaporize or
which one is going to have more of its
molecules turning into vapor I guess you
could say turning into vapor more easily
well you immediately see that they both
have hydrogen bonds you have this
hydrogen bond between the partially
negative end and the partial positive
ends hydrogen bond between the partial
negative end and the partial positive
ends but the other thing that you notice
is that I guess you can think of it on a
per molecule basis on average you have
fewer hydrogen bonds on the ethanol than
you have on the water ethanol oxygen is
more electronegative we already know
it's more electronegative than hydrogen
it's also more electronegative than
carbon but it's a lot more
electronegative than hydrogen so you
have this imbalance here and then on top
of that this carbon you have a lot more
atoms here in which to distribute a
partial charge so there could be a very
weak partial charge distributed here
amongst the carbons but you have a
stronger partial charge on the hydrogen
but it's not going to be strong as what
you have here because once again you
have a larger molecule to kind of
distribute especially around this carbon
to help dissipate charge in so you're
going to have weaker partial charges
here and they're occurring in fewer
places so you have less hydrogen bonding
on the ethanol than you have on the
water so let me write that you have less
hydrogen bonding less hydrogen bonding
and as we've already talked about in the
liquor
State and frankly in the solid state as
well the hydrogen bonding is what is
keeping these things together that's
what's keeping the water together
flowing next to each other this is
what's keeping the ethanol together and
so if you have less hydrogen if you have
let me write this down less hydrogen
bonding if it actually has more hydrogen
atoms per molecule but if you have less
hydrogen bonding that's going to take
less energy to break these things free
so before I even talk about breaking
things free and these molecules turning
into vapor essentially turns their gas
state let's just think about how that
happens when we talk about the
temperature of a system we're really
just talking about the average kinetic
energy but each molecule remember
they're all bouncing around in all
different ways this one might have for
example a much higher kinetic energy
than this one they're all moving in
different directions this one might have
a little bit higher and maybe this one
all of a sudden has a really high
kinetic energy because it's just been
knocked in just the exact right ways and
it's enough to overcome both these
hydrogen bonds over here and the
pressure from the air above it remember
this isn't happening in a vacuum you
have air you have air up here air
molecules I'll just draw them generic
you have different types of things
nitrogen carbon dioxide etc etc but if I
just draw generic air molecules there's
also some pressure from these things
bouncing around but this one might have
enough this one this particular molecule
might have enough kinetic energy to
overcome the hydrogen bonds and overcome
the pressure from the molecules above it
to essentially vaporize to turn into its
gas state and the same thing might be
true over here maybe this is the
molecule that has the super high kinetic
energy to be able to break free in that
case it is going to turn into it is
going to turn into its gaseous state the
hydrogen bonds are going to break apart
and it's going to be so far from any of
its its sibling molecules I guess you
could say from the other ethanol
molecules and it won't be able to form
new hydrogen bonds same thing with this
one once it vaporizes out in gaseous
state it's much further from any other
water molecules it's not going to be
able to fine form those hydrogen bonds
with them but because there's more
hydrogen bonds here to break than here
you could imagine it would take on
average more heat to vaporize this thing
than to vaporize this thing and that is
indeed the case and the term for how
much heat do you need to vaporize a
certain mass
of a substance you can imagine is called
the heat of vaporization let me write
that down
heat heat of vaporization heat of
vaporization and you can imagine it is
higher for water than it is for ethanol
and I will give you the numbers here at
least ones that I've been able to look
up I found slightly different numbers
and depending on which resource I looked
at but what I found for water the heat
of vaporization is 2260 joules per gram
or instead of using joules remember
Jules is unit of energy it could be a
unit of heat instead of joules if you
want to think of it in terms of calories
that's equivalent to 541 calories
calories per gram while the heat of
vaporization for ethanol is a good bit
lower the heat of vaporization for
ethanol so let me make this clear this
is this right over here is water that's
for water and the same thing for our
ethanol the heat of vaporization for
ethanol is based on what I looked up is
841 joules per gram or if we want to
write them as calories 200 and 201
calories per gram which means it would
require roughly 201 calories to
evaporate to fully vaporize a gram of
ethanol at standard temperature keeping
the temperature constant so we could
talk more about that in other videos but
the big the big thing that we're talking
about here is that look it just requires
less energy to vaporize this thing and
you could run the experiment take a
glass of water equivalent glasses fill
them up the same amount of time a glass
of water
and a glass of ethanol and then a V see
how long it takes you know you could put
a heat lamp on top of them or you could
just put them outside where they're
experiencing the same atmospheric
conditions the same the same sun's rays
and see how what's the difference how
long how much how much more energy how
much more time does it take for the
water to evaporate then the ethanol and
there's a similar idea here which is
boiling point we've all boiled things
boiling point is the point at which the
the vapor pressure from from the from
the substance is is is has become equal
to and it starts to
overcome the the pressure from just a
regular atmospheric pressure and so you
could imagine that water has a higher
temperature at which it starts to boil
then ethanol and that is indeed the case
water's boiling point is exactly 100
degrees Celsius in fact water's boiling
point was an important data point for
even establishing the Celsius scale so
by definition it's 100 degrees Celsius
while ethanol boiling point is
approximately 78 degrees Celsius so it
boils at a much lower temperature and
that's because there's just fewer
hydrogen bonds to actually break